sans parler de chaleur caniculaire le
thermomètre est monté d'un coup à paris
en région parisienne l'occasion de nous
intéresser aux personnes les plus
vulnérables aux personnes âgées
depuis la vague de chaleur de l'été 2003
les maisons de retraite et 7 de
s'équiper pour faire face à de fortes
températures josé blanc lapierre
flibusterie 35° allons en moins
l'occasion ou jamais de tester le tout
nouveau climatiseurs après six heures
dans le gers et littéraire dans cette
maison de retraite
on a fait le choix de l'appareil qui se
déplacent d'un salon à l'autre petit
mais efficace semble-t-il au sol
ça se rafraîchir
et l'ambiance dans la pièce d'à côté où
l'on attend sans bouger le moindre
souffle d'air infirmières et aides
soignantes se consacre à une tâche
prioritaire faire boire les
pensionnaires beaucoup de personnages
influents la sensation de soif et de
plus ces dames est diabétique
donc auquel vois mon sillon plus que les
autres c'est sur qu'il faudrait au moins
que chacun boivent un verre d'eau toutes
les heures ici l'arrivée de la chaleur
inquiète 4 climatiseur pour 200
résidents ne serait probablement pas
suffisant
s'il fallait affronter une nouvelle
canicule là on va quand même être
gratter un peu puisqu'on alice tort
quand même qui vont à mon avis atténuer
quand même en fait dans ma chambre il
faisait 29 filière encore fiches pilotes
pas de ventilateur de richmond
mais pour le directeur le problème
majeur reste le manque de personnel si
nous avions une nouvelle canicule
je pense que nous aurions moins de décès
que nous n'en avons eu en 2003 fort
heureusement les malheureusement compte
tenu que nous manquons encore
cruellement de professionnels auprès des
personnes âgées
nous aurions sans doute encore un
nouveau drame à connaître et ici avec
seulement une infirmière pour 60
résidents l'entrée dans l'été est
synonyme de travail encore plus intense